what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some news that might
shake up the MCU a little bit at least
for a few characters and a few different
MCU projects and if you are one of the
many fans who are wondering about the
upcoming story for the Scarlet Witch and
the MCU this is some news that might
take her story and a little bit of a
different unexpected Direction however
one that I will be very excited to see
because this is about vision and his
upcoming project and his kids but not
Billy and Tommy not the kids that he had
with Wanda and Wanda Vision but new kids
that kind of come from Wanda but not
entirely and I'll explain that in just a
bit but this project is going to have
big connections not only to Wanda slash
the Scarlet Witch but also to armor Wars
and Ultron and it's been said that
Ultron could be returning in armor Wars
that's just a rumor for now but we do
know that the new New Vision spectral
Vision as people are calling him is
derived from Ultron so we very well
could see The Return of Ultron pretty
soon in the MCU but let's talk about the
upcoming Vision Quest news and how this
is going to directly affect the Scarlet
Witch this report today is coming from
The Insider can we get some toast on
Twitter they tweeted Ben and Vivian
Vision will make their MCU debut in
Vision Quest now this is really cool and
exciting news because like I mentioned
this does make for a very interesting
story with the Scarlet Witch we know
she's not done in the MCU we know she
has a lot of story left and even though
Vision wasn't really brought up at all
in the Multiverse of Madness we know
that she still loves vision and he's
still around kind of enough to spark
some emotion and Wanda and their story
is very interesting in the comics Vin
and Vivian Vision Vin and Viv are made
or created by Vision in the comics for
him to kind of attempt to have of a
normal Family Vision was trying to
humanize himself so he thought that the
process of having a family would help
him do that so he created two kids and a
wife Virginia notice all the v's Vision
Virginia Vin Vivian plus not to mention
Vin Vivian and Virginia all have the
last name of vision Vision was real
creative there but what's really
interesting about this story is that
Virginia was basically created from the
brain waves of the Scarlet Witch in the
comics wanna Envision aren't always
together they separate and Wanda
actually gives her brain waves to Vision
as a gift and it's from these brain
waves that he models his new wife he
then takes his own brain waves and
Virginia's brain waves which are
basically Wanda's brain waves and he
designs and makes his kids the twins Viv
and Vin so you could see how this story
could be pretty interesting in terms of
taking place in the MCU if these kids
are somehow derived of Wanda in some way
shaper form that might conflict Wanda an
awful bit right now she's on the search
for Billy and Tommy the kids that she
loves and kids that she created in one
division to have with vision so this
story is kind of the opposite of One
Division it's Vision creating his own
family and it will get really
interesting if Wanda comes in and finds
out Vision has a new family and he even
has kids and if they are kind of based
off of the brain waves from Wanda then
she might consider them kind of her kids
as well but at the same time Billy and
Tommy are going to be returning to the
MCU in fact can we get some toast also
reported that Billy and Tommy will
return in the Children's Crusade which
is basically going to be a Young
Avengers project so the water is getting
pretty muddy here and we haven't even
started to talk about Stark Tech and
armor Wars but there is another layer
added to this when you consider that
this spectral vision isn't really the
vision that knows Wanda however it does
seem like at the end of one One Division
in the finale the other Vision somehow
made spectral Vision tap into the
memories that the original Vision had so
there actually is hope there that the
vision that we knew and that we loved
and that more importantly Wanda knew and
loved could possibly return and if this
happens they're gonna have a pretty big
family now two Android twins two magical
kids and also an Android other wife that
Vision created for himself we'll have to
see how that plays out there's
definitely some drama there so this
story with the Scarlet Witch could play
out to be pretty wild but we're also
going to dive into how this affects
armor Wars and the mcu's tech side right
now we know that secret invasion is
going to include Roadie in it and secret
invasion is going to lead directly into
armor Wars sword created the spectral
vision and Roadie might have a problem
with this since he helped fight Ultron
envision's family that he made both his
wife and two kids all basically have the
same powers that he does they have the
power of flight superhuman strength and
they can phase through things this is
probably going to be on roady's radar as
a possible threat he knew the original
vision and knows that this isn't him but
what he probably is worried about is who
exactly could control Vision or maybe
the opposite what if nobody can control
him and he's too strong if him and his
family decide to simply try to do things
themselves and possibly take something
over but going back to the rumor that
Ultron could possibly return in armor
Wars that makes sense we know armor Wars
is going to be about Tony Stark's
technology the Iron Man Tech falling
into the wrong hands now some of those
wrong hands are going to be scroll
that's just going to be some of the
effects of secret Invasion that's about
to open up the MCU to a completely
different story some of these Heroes
might not have even been the heroes that
we thought they were not saying none of
them participated in Infinity war or end
game or something like that but perhaps
the Scrolls disguise themselves as the
heroes to do some things that normal
people couldn't do at some point I'm
sure this will all be be revealed in
secret Invasion but going back to Tony
Stark what's really interesting is that
Viv almost dies in the comics the Grim
Reaper slices her body and in order to
fix her vision gets the help of Tony
Stark and his technology perhaps
something similar could happen in armor
Wars where vision's kids get hurt and
vision needs Tony Stark technology in
order to fix them and since its Vision
here he has the powers of vision like we
mentioned being able to phase through
things in superhuman strength I'm
assuming that he's not going to ask he's
just going to take or if he asks and
they say no then he's gonna take anyways
plus not to mention there still could be
some Ultron programming inside of him so
if people turn on him that could come
out plus he could connect to Stark Tech
again and of course the internet and
everything that is on the internet and
Ultron could come out in the comics
Ultron is never really dead to kill
Ultron you would literally have to get
rid of every single little bitty trace
of him on online in person and any Bots
that he would have his Consciousness is
basically transferred over and over
again through the internet so Ultron
could totally return in this new
spectral Vision there are many different
ways this could go and hopefully Vision
remains a good guy although the last
time we saw spectral Vision he wasn't
exactly a good guy sword was using him
at their will but again our vision
seemed to open his eyes and give him
some memories so hopefully that'll be
enough to get him to turn kind of good
and perhaps seek out Wanda but like I
said he's still tied to Ultron and what
will happen in armor Wars well we don't
know right now but we do know one thing
for sure Vision having kids is
definitely going to be an interesting
story in the MCU especially for Wanda's
future their paths are bound across
again and when they do it's gonna be
pretty interesting but hey let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below what do you think about
Vision having kids and what would this
mean to Wanda let us know your thoughts
down below also big thank you to all of
the patrons that we've had so far thank
you to Ryan tomorrow who became a new
Patron today and thank you to everybody
who has supported the channel if you'd
like exclusive benefits we don't post on
YouTube you can check out our patreon
down below we also have a website that
we post to many times a day and of
course a Discord server if you'd like to
join that as well be sure to subscribe
and leave a comment to enter our
giveaway you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof
baby